also ich habe mich für uns für ein paar
tage nehmen zu lassen weil die ins ärzte
müssen ja geimpft sein
und ich bin auch ebenfalls und kann als
ihm was sozusagen nicht die impflinge
gefährden weil es jetzt um games und ich
habe den impfstoff gut verteidigen also
sagen ein bisschen fieber schüttelfrost
gegeben aber also das ist hier zu
erwarten und ich habe ja immer diesen
impfstoff auch empfohlen
ich bin jetzt noch kann ich bin so noch
keine 60 aber ich habe das quasi auf
meine eigene kappe genommen und also der
impfstoff ist definitiv ein sehr guter
impfstoffes kann im stoff zweiter klasse
er wird sehr zuverlässig und außerdem
angeboten wird über 60 der sorte noch
nehmen wir sind bild und wir liefert dir
deine news auf youtube zum nächsten
video kommst du hier
und vergiss bitte nicht unseren kanal zu
abonnieren